[Music]
we are gathered here today to join V and
Thomas in holy matrimony you're taking
this so well he's a good man you hated
this guy
you've grown very close welcoming a new
parent not that close so father father
father no you're not my father
sorry are you the other it's really the
rabbit story I just wrote it down look
it's Peter Rabbit oh I hate that I'm the
face of this he's naughty what I knew
Peter that depends who's asking Peter
told you he has it in for me he was
talking to all of us
I'm talking to you Peter specifically
stay out of trouble trouble if that's
who they think I am maybe I'd be better
off without them
[Music]
oh come on
[Music]
what are you okay goody-goody you gonna
turn me I know pretty goody apparently
I'm a fatty fatty is your name Peter
rabbits yeah I was best friends with
your dad
my name's Barnabas you're a fierce bad
rabbit just like where are the rabbits
back in their burrows snug as a bug in a
rug
yeah spread out
this
[Music]
join them a little and that's why adults
shouldn't do kid stuff
[Music]